Let's try another problem on inverse variation using light. The intensity of
light varies inveresely as a square of the distance from the source. So think
about if we shine the light unto a screen. This screen would have a light spot
on it and this would be the intnsity of light on the screen. We measure this
intensity on whats called a foot candle, so if a light source is 5 feet from a
screen There will be an intensity of 2 foot candles knowing this let's find the
intensity on the screen if this light source was moved to 20 feet away. Now you
might never have heard of a foot candle before but just know that foot candle is
a way that we can measure intensity. Look this up if you want to learn more
about light and foot candles. Distance here is just measured in feet, so 5 feet
would be a distance, as would 20 feet. So try to figure this problem out and
remember that the intensity of light is varying inversely with the square of the
distance. Think carefully about the proportion you need to setup and when you're
ready put your answer here.